hello everyone and welcome to the 2019
championship showdown chess960 edition
or the chest 9 LX Edition as they're
calling it it's day two and it's Fabiano
Carano vs. garry kasparov again Bobby
with the white pieces cuz para with the
black pieces some how those games seem
to be the most enjoyable ones and after
they won cuz part of had a lot of
promising positions but in the end he
was only able to get a draw out of four
games Caruana won the other three and
they too started similar in the two
rapid games Kasparov outplayed Carolina
in both rapid games but in the end
scored only half a point out of those
rapid games and this is now the first
game of the blitz section so let's check
it out and see what happened there so in
this game in the rapid game Corona
tried it would be for that game ended in
a draw but here for the blitz section we
have E for by Caruana which is which is
quite funny since this is chess 960 but
also I forgot to mention if someone you
don't know before they start playing
both players get an hour to analyze the
starting position so the the starting
position from day two is different than
the starting position from day one and
they each have a second a helper to help
them so Kasparov is analyzing with Peter
Svidler
one hour before the games start and the
Fabiano Caruana is analyzing with 11
aragon so let's continue
efore we've b6 by Kasparov and now II
five let me just fix that with d6 now
back as part of in the night G to f3
will D captures on e5 Knight captures by
Khurana and then out nice to d6 nicely
developing also guarding the f7 square
you don't wanna allow night f7 check
with d4 by Caruana and now again f6
seems like Kasparov is playing f6 in
every game we have Knight back to f3 and
now g5 by Caspar of preparing g4 with
Quinta III and now Kasparov takes
advantage of far be developing the Queen
on e3 to play knife to h6 now the knight
can come to f5 and this will come with
an attack on the White Queen with a
queenside castle by Caruana
and now Knight
five s planned Queen to a three and now
G for so of course Fabi plays 95
capturing would only only help white for
example if captures capture see you
cannot move the night due to the pin and
this would be okay for white but here
Kasparov finds a very interesting idea
which basically wins the pawn Knight
captures on d4 rook captures and pawn
captures on e5 now so now the sperm has
doubled pawns with his Kings still in
the center but he's not afraid of the
position will Brooke back to d1 and now
push up to h6
this comes with check and with this
Kasparov prepares the Castle kingside
now we have King to be won and now
Kasparov castles King side and it seems
a weird when you look at a castling in
chess960 but yeah you still when you
Castle King said you're king and rook go
into the same position where the king
and rook would be in a classical chess
game so castles and now b3 Khurana opens
up the dark square Bishop and Bishop
back to g7 Kasparov is ready now to add
F and E 5 4 and 2
well counter Fabiano's dark square
bishop and here f3 by Corona h3 seems
the interesting here you want to capture
here and open up your H file for the
rook but here black can either push g3
and not allow you to open it or just
play rook captures an f2 and after
capture screen captures in g4 and the
blacks development is much better and
much more useful than the whites a
semi-open h-file saw after Bishop g7 f3
by karana and the now comes Queen to f5
piling up on the f3 square we have
Bishop to e2 and now even efore efore is
an excellent move because it prevents
this Knight from ever being developed
will not ever but for a very long time
and since this is a blaze game that's
basically ever with Bishop captures King
captures and now F captures on g4
attacking the Queen and now Queen to e5
still this pawn is nicely standing here
the knight cannot be developed Fabiano
cannot connect his rooks and now Queen
captures an a7 with such a
with Kasparov's leading development
Bobby decides it's okay to capture a
pawn is it okay well let's see what
Kasparov plays will worship the b7 now
with ideas of kicking away the queen
with rock day 8 or even trapping the
Queen
so Corona has to move the Queen way we
have Queen to a4 and now Luke the f2 now
Kasparov is preparing rogue beat f8 to
double up on the F file so the bishop is
under attack you have to do something
about this with Bishop to f1 by Caruana
and now Ruby to f8 going after the
bishop and the point is that the bishop
cannot be saved if you play you can go
here you can go here you can go here if
you try Bishop to e6 you're getting
Bishop captures on a6 Queen captures and
Knight d5 and there's no defense against
Knight c3 trick whatever you play and
really there is no good move to play
here you still can't move the night you
can play route d7 but then Knight c3
check and after king c1 you're just
gonna get Knight d1 and there's very
little you can do against Queen e1 mate
a queen a one mate even capturing
results in the same mate as the route
controls the second rank so here you
would adjust after this nightly one move
I have to lose a lot of material and in
the end it would all be over
so after Ruby to f8 with Bishop to d3
karana finds the strongest move
recommended by the engine and now okay
casparo grabs the piece right away you
get Knight characteris and now the Queen
and rook are under attack
Queen e2 let's say you capture rook
captures an f2 and Caruana I wanted to
play this position having a rope for a
knight and the bishop because parov is
still better but Kasparov does not grab
the piece right away after Bishop to d3
Kasparov goes Queen to c5 now this is a
much stronger idea as the bishop still
has nowhere to go and the problem is now
after characters and Knight captures
you're getting Queen captures and c2 as
the rook and queen are now both
attacking the c2 pawn so rook the c1
karana the defense and the now rook to
e8 bringing the rook into the attack now
Queen to d7 going after the e7 pawn and
now Luke back to f7 defending while also
attacking here Kaspar
threatening Bishop to see it which will
trap her honest Queen Queen t6 preparing
to run away with the Queen but it's not
working bishop to see it still and
karana doesn't really have a good square
for the Queen so he plays before he
wants to give up at the b4 pawn so he
can retreat the be three but Kasparov
says that will not work but she captures
any six by Kasparov be captures in c5
and now e captures on d3 just grabbing
that Bishop it's a free piece because if
you capture here then you just get the -
casparo will not win more material so
after each capture some d3 with nitrous
on d3 and now Knight to e4 with rook
cita II 1 attacking the knight and now
Bishop captures an a2 with Czech finally
casparo grabs this pawn with King b2 and
out push it back to d5 just defending
that night and here
Bobby's just down a full piece and this
is completely lost for him but it's a
blitz game so he will try to create some
tricks here maybe maybe he can flak as
part of who knows anything goes in blitz
so nice the b4 and now comes east six
just defending that bishops seek after
sun b6 but now c5 Casper of sacrifices
upon to get two connected points so
Knight captures pawn captures now the
two connected points are very strong and
looked at e3 preparing to defend the
beasts exponent would rook the b3 we
look to b7 but the pond cannot be
defended
we have rook to be 3 and now rook the a6
Kasparov is now ready to win the
temporarily sacrificed pawn rook to d1
going after the d5 pawn and now d4 we
have looked the one attacking the knight
and now Knight to d6 and Fabi retreats
King b1 he doesn't want night c4 to come
with check but now rook captures rook
egg after Sun b6 rook captures rook
captures with check and now King
retreats the c1 and finally King f6
Kasparov starts bringing the King into
the game with g5 check hoping for
characters in the rookie 5 check will
disconnect the pawns but Kasparov says
no way he plays King a 5
we have roopd 7 by Fabi going after the
h7 pawn but now Knight e4 rook captures
an H 7 and now Fabi
casparo in no rush to win material he
prepares a nice mating net Knight to c3
and now if Bobby plays something like
age 4 then you have a nice rugby one
check King d2 and the rook d1 mate as
the pond and Knight are creating a wall
so the White King cannot escape after
Knight c3 Bobby starts running with the
king king d2 and now see for those pawns
are getting closer and closer to the
White King we have rook d7 going after
the pawn and now king g5 defending with
rookie 7 check King d5 route d7 check
and now King back to e5 here players
repeated once keep the f4 by Kasparov
and now g6 and here I think Bobby had
like two seconds on the clock
there is the delay so it's not really 2
seconds whereas Kasparov had I believe 9
seconds on the clock and g6 just gives
up a pawn but at least he's trying to
make a spur of thing but coz probably
just grabs the pawn g3 check King back
to f3 and now rook to f7 sorry rook to
f7 check King G for Ruby 7 check King d5
will group d7 check in now King c5 we
have looked a c7 check King B 5 and now
rook back to the 7 attacking the d4 pawn
Knight e4 check back as part of kinky -
in the now King c5 know if rook c7 check
Kasparov can play King before in King c3
and guard the pawn from c3 so kink the
f3 by Caruana and not knight back to d6
with 84 Khurana starts pushing his
passport rook f6 check King e2 and now
Knight to e4 with rook to e7 attacking
the knight but not Knight captures and
g3 with check King you want with c3 now
and it was in this position that Coronas
time ran out because there is nothing
well he only had 2 seconds and when the
delay ran out he's two seconds ran out
of it very quickly as there is nothing
he can do here you can see with c3 cross
portalguard's the d2 squared the night
covers F
Andy to the route controls the F file
and Roop to f1 will be made so there is
nothing you can do to avoid it you can
you can play can be won but then after
rook f1 check you will have to trade
rooks and now you're you know completely
lost endgame work as part has a night
and you don't but yeah after c3 I
believe his time ran out or he may be
just resigned but I do believe his time
ran out and the first win for Garry
Kasparov in this match after a struck
struggling for so long but it was just
insane I really enjoyed I was following
the second day all the games and it was
really really intense because Kasparov
played him in both both of the rapid
games but he was burning so much time he
he it's like he's trying to play perfect
moves he he's trying to create every
game he wants it to be an immortal game
but Bobby's just playing normal moves
saves time and then cos probably just
goes into time trouble and he either
blunders or or fights for a draw but
Kasparov said after winning this game he
said that he can fight all opponents but
not each time is the most powerful
opponent none of us can beat but he
still said that today they are going
into day three of the chess960 and
Kasparov says that he would not like
this match to end without him you know
grabbing at least one win in the rapids
so we'll see how that goes
definitely we're gonna follow it up but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank viatra
Holland and Finn Peters for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual we
can check - in my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon are continuing this short
coverage of the chess960 championship
showdown a continuing the capablanca
saga and checking up on your suggestions
I think oh I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day